es gibt ein absolutes ende aller
maßnahmen und alle maßnahmen enden
spätestens mit dem frühlingsbeginn am 20
märz
2290 wir wissen ja alle dass dieses
versprechen jetzt nicht so ganz
eingehalten wurde ich würde sogar sagen
gebrochen es gibt quasi ist seit früher
keine echten coup viele mehr es gibt
keine
typischen kurve lungenentzündung mehr
wie viele liegen jetzt im krankenhaus
mit 19 also ich kann sagen in der
charité sind es derzeit etwa 100 und
verfielen
mit einem positiven test das ist ein
großer unterschied es sind patienten die
entweder wegen primär einer cupid
infektion in die klinik gekommen sind
oder aber auch wegen einer anderen
erkrankung jetzt mit einem schweren ko
witt verlaufen aber der professor es
geht damit kann man doch nicht arbeiten
wir müssen doch wissen wie viele
patienten exakt wegen kurve dem
krankenhaus den